everyone happy new year
so while back did you see those rumors
about a proposed Nvidia 2060 dpu that
wouldn't be an RT X card and so
presumably wouldn't support rate racing
or any of the other new cheering
features
yeah that's turned out to be completely
rubbish as the RT X 2060 is here and it
is indeed a full cheering model priced
at 350 dollars it's got RT features it
runs TL SS and it supports a variable
rate shading it's the full chewing
feature set just shrunk down for a lower
price point but yes shrunk down
obviously means lower performance which
raises the question of just how capable
this card is going to be the answer well
it's pretty good actually
yes three hundred and fifty dollars
means that the RT X 2060 is a lot
pricier than the old 1060 but as we
shall discover performance is solid so
the nuts and bolts level what is that
RTX 2260 well looking at the card itself
and yeah we have the founders Edition
here it's all looking very similar to
the 27 TFE and that's because it's using
a cut-down version at the same tu 106
processor the board itself retains the
same hdmi 2.0 and USB C connections as
the other cars in the RT X lineup but in
common with the 27 TFE there are just
two display ports and a dual link DVI
the inclusion of DVI EF or a card
primarily aimed at 1080p and 1440p
gaming I'd say it's a good port to have
power is delivered with a single 8 pin
power input again in common with the RT
X 2017 build quality is pretty decent
here overall in common with the other
founders cards and then it's the sense
that you're getting a premium product
here there's a 160 watt TDP so this is a
fair step up from the GTX 1060 kinda
sitting between 1070 and 1080 instead so
in terms of the silicon itself to 2,304
CUDA cores of the 2070 a pair back to
1920 for the twin
sixty so that'll be eighty three point
three percent of the full complement
memory bandwidth is cut down however we
all know 192 bit bus here with three
hundred and thirty six gigabytes per
second is bandwidth that's not too far
off the GTX 1080 actually thanks to the
transition to G DDR six so paired with
during's memory compression improvements
pretty good match for the performance
offer in terms of rate racing prowess
per Nvidia's Giga a metric the specs are
pretty clear we're at 50% of the prowess
of the twenty atti sixty two point five
percent of twenty eighty and again
eighty three point three percent of the
twenty seventy can it run
battlefield 5 rate racing bit well the
recent patch from Dyess improves
performance from launch dramatically
still looks phenomenal and so Nvidia
cites 1080p gaming here at full ultra
settings without 4dx are at 60 frames
per second so here's the thing strictly
speaking I don't see anything wrong with
that claim but I kind of feel the
implication is that you're always at 60
frames per second or better that's
certainly not the case now of course the
funny thing about frame rate averages is
that they're exactly that averages the
game could conceivably run at 35 frames
per second if there's sufficient content
running elsewhere at much higher than 60
frames per second and this will then
average out bottom line though I demand
a sixty minimum and the reality is that
as things are right now the 2060 doesn't
deliver that so here's the thing
battlefield 5 was I suspect built with a
specific render budget in mind for all
of the specific content you know by and
large certain features add on additional
costs that scale according to the
settings you choose and of course your
chosen hardware from what I can see
though the lender budget balance dice
established without RT features enabled
is blown to pieces
once it is enabled some scenes run
beautifully smooth at 1080p
others are far far heavier
I'd really like to see some kind of
dynamic resolution scaling and effective
again I only had limited time for
testing out quite like to return to it
especially since a ton of extra overhead
will be given once the game gets a DL SS
patch bottom line though a bunch of
users were predicting disaster with a
ray tracing beam pointless on the lower
end
RTX cards bearing in mind the first
gained to utilize arti is running and
producing a decent albeit far from
flawless experience well I think
developers just need time with a new
hardware the bottom line is that in time
cards like 2060 and 2017 will form the
bulk of the RT X user base and so it
would be madness not to produce
experiences that run well on those
products but yet the performance
enhancing DL SS will certainly help them
speaking of which let's crack on with a
look at how well the 2016 utilizes some
of those other nuturing features DL SS
is the technology that uses a deep
learning algorithm paired with
cheering's tensor cores to effectively
upscale the image you're looking at
Final Fantasy 15 here running at 4k on
max settings and I'd say that whether
you're using taa or D LSS you're gonna
get dips under 30 frames per second here
but to be fair all of the game works
features are enabled here and in real
life actually playing the game turf
works or turf effects or whatever that's
the only one I've actually recommend
using bottom line though the results are
fascinating in this benchmark the GTX
1080 outperforms the RCX 2060 with taa
but with DL SS active we get frame rates
than just 6% short of the r-tx 2080
running with CA a of course that's a 39%
boost to performance a similar thing
happens in the epic infiltrator demo
we're comparing taa to taa we have a GTX
1080 is around 3% faster than our CX
2060 however again with TLS s active the
performance uplift brings frame rates
closer into line with the 2018 and just
a reminder here the 2080 is pretty much
on par with the GTX 1082
I in performance terms not bad for yes
we're going to come down to image
quality really something that we'll be
looking at really soon when more DL SS
content is available based on what I'm
seeing with Final Fantasy 15 though I'm
optimistic about this technology
another new cheering feature worth
discussing is variable late shading I'm
not going to go too deeply into the
details of how this technology works
Alex did a super video about that which
I shall link in the video description
below
why spend precious resources rendering
pixels you're not likely to see whether
that's in like darker areas or in fast
motion reduce the complexity they're
lower frame rendering times and get
higher performance it's that simple so
I'm going to compare the r-tx 2060 to
the GTX 1080 here using the first game
to support the feature Wolfenstein the
new Colossus this is a modern game
engine and even without VRS active the
2060 can outperform the 1080 by just a
touch
but 1080p is about three percent faster
there are VRS modes that target either
quality performance or a little bit of
both
and yeah that balanced mode is the b4
dot higher resolutions basically a match
for the performance mode however at
1080p
there's clearer scaling as we move
through each mode we essentially gain
three to four percent more performance
at best VRS adds around 11% to frame
rate in our New Orleans test run with
this feature then the r-tx 2060 can best
the GTX 280 by a maximum of fifteen
percent yes only one game supports VRS
at the moment this one but variable rate
shading is a feature that has been
coveted by developers for years that is
finally here and I expect it to be
supportive more widely all of which
leads us onto vaster ization performance
so thus far we've seen the Final Fantasy
15 benchmark see the 1080 outperforming
2060 while Wolfenstein 2 even without
VRS sees the opposite 2016 moves ahead
of 1080 so for a three hundred and fifty
dollar card with all the bonus curing
stuff this isn't bad at all but just how
fast is it when we take a look
more titles I actually think we have a
winning package here but actually
pegging how fast the 20 60 years
compared to a specific Pascal card isn't
easy well I can say is this similar to
other cheering cards we are seeing a big
price bump for the nude product it is
$100 on top of the 10 60 s $250 asking
price but in fairness it is a ton faster
obviously this of a quick look at a
legacy title Crysis 3 the 2060 delivers
56% more performance for 40% more cash
it's 57 percent faster rx 580 and 42
percent faster than rx 590 that was a
Tomb Raider here next to represent a
more modern game 2060 59% faster than
the 10 60 52% for us than the 580 and
there's a 40 percent uplift over the new
rx 590 and video is presenting the RT X
2060 as its new 1080p champion with
excellent 1440 feet performance as well
but really this card is of a placement
for higher tier offerings 1070 1070 TI
1080 these are kind of better comparison
points so yeah the 1070 is left for dust
and essentially we're looking at a
performance level that sees the RT X
2060 match or exceed 1070 TI while
getting very close to 1080 performance
matching it or even beating in some
scenarios I'm not going to dwell too
much on the AMD side of things here but
suffice to say that the 2060 poses
problems for the Vega cards bearing in
mind it's 350 dollar price point out of
11 titles tested across 1080p in 1440p
resolutions to 2060 is faster than Vega
56 in ten of them only far cry 5 at 1080
P sees that 56 moved slightly ahead and
only then because of a performance but
of sorts at the beginning of the bench
otherwise like for like across the run
of play the 2060 also does a fairly good
job of keeping pace and sometimes mildly
exceeding Vega 64 as well
and yes that's with the AMD cars
rebadged from scratch with the latest
drivers
even AMD's established champions like
battlefield 100 dx12 Caesar 2060 pull
ahead of the Vega 56 at 1080p though
curiously the 2016 loses pace at 1440p
and 4k with Vega gaining more
performance relatively but one thing
I've noticed is that the 2016 just like
other cheering cards does tend to run
better on more modern games even if we
look at earlier and more recent entries
from the same franchises so let's take a
look at Assassin's Creed Odyssey V
fascinating results the 2060 is
effectively on par with a 1080 at 1440p
or slightly slower at Full HD up against
the 1070 TI it's on par at 1080p but
faster at 1440p so yeah remember when I
said it was hard to peg the new card up
against a specific Pascal model good
example here then however in the old
Assassin's Creed unity built on the same
engine an older version of it obviously
any advantage to 2060 has against the
1070 TI vanishes at both resolutions and
the GTX 1080
obviously has a clear lead you could see
something similar in the last two Tomb
Raider games as well if you take a look
at the rise of the Tomb Raider benchmark
we actually see one of the rare examples
of the 2060 being beaten by the 1070 TI
and believe me this doesn't happen very
often
whether you're at full HD or 1440p
resolution 1070 Ti has a three to four
percentage point lead in this game
GC X 1080 also takes a commanding lead
14 to 15 percent depending on the
resolution
however fast-forward to the recently
released shadow of the Tomb Raider the
situation changes somewhat and again it
is using a more modern version of the
same engine RT x 20 69% fast intense 17
t eye at full HD 6 % faster at 1440p by
extension the GTX 1080s lead over the
2060 taken down to 4 to 5 percent so
yeah that's kind of the performance tale
so you can expect pretty much around the
1070 TI to 1080 area
so if either the Tomb Raider is
something of a weak spot for the 2060
how does the older 1070 compare I mean
that was something of a landmark card
delivering title next Maxwell
performance to the mainstream well even
on rise to 2060 is still 13 percent
faster and that increases to around 20
percent with shadow that's a solid chunk
of performance then for a three hundred
and fifty dollar product but yes the
newer games where are cheering generally
performs best now Crysis 3 is and
probably always will be in our legacy
titles selection and it caused some
hiccups for the r-tx 2080 something a
bit similar is happening here it's a
couple of percentage points lower than
the 1070 TI regardless of the resolution
you're playing you'd be unlikely to
notice the difference in actual gameplay
but what it does mean is that the GTX
1080 has a huge lead here around 16% now
compare and contrast with Wolfenstein
the new Colossus now we've already seen
at 1080p the 2060 inches ahead of GT X
1080 and it's 10% faster than 1070 TI
it's also where posts its biggest leap
ahead of gtx 1060 delivering an
astonishing uplift in performance of 75
percent tuned VRS to performance spec
and remember this feature is not
available on Pascal and that lead
extends to 92 percent almost a doubling
of performance now this is an outlier at
the moment but if you cast your mind
back to GTX 780 Ti vs GTX 980 right at
the launch there wasn't much in E in
performance terms but as that Maxwell
architecture matured it left the old
Kepler cards like the 780ti in the dust
maybe the same thing will happen here so
I think we have a measure of the 2060s
performance then as I said it's kind of
like a spectrum of frame rates that
ranges from a touch under the standard
set by 1070 GI to a touch over GTX 1080
depending on the game
how does it stack up against the rest of
the r-tx lineup so this is an
interesting one and video is really
positioning this is of 1080p card but
come on 1070 TI 1080 those are 1440p
champions all of the benchmarks I've
done using an i7 8700 K with an
all-court turbo at 4.7 gigahertz and
that's a ton of CPU power there but the
bottom line is that we can hit CPU
limits which are influencing the result
so case in point SAS ins creed Odyssey
really CPU heavy this one at 1080p 27 T
is only 12 percent faster than the 2060
with the 2080 delivering only a 21
percent boost those figures increase to
15% and 30% of 1440p and rise again to
23 percent faster for the 2070 47
percent for the 2080 so what's happening
here is that as we scale the resolution
ladder the CPU is less of a limiting
factor and the GPUs have more room to
breathe bottom line though even the 2060
can hit CPU limits even with a fast 8700
K so check out this crisis 1080p
benchmark we've got the 2060 stacked up
against gtx 1070 which is less powerful
as we've established and then more
capable r-tx cards now notice where the
graph lines intersect they're at this
point you are getting identical
performance from all of those cards and
that's because we are using the same CPU
which is hitting the same limit and yeah
really that is an 8700 K 4.7 gigahertz
in court over its stupendously fast so
on less capable processors I'd seriously
recommend 1440p as the minimum for
general gaming to remove that CPU
bottleneck ok so let's wrap up 1070 TI
to kinda 1080 performance for 350
dollars with the promise of DL SS and
VRS on top and yeah ray-tracing -
overall I think this is a strong deal
but let's be clear here what it doesn't
deliver is a Pascal
generational leap in performance but it
is well priced for the frame race it
delivers compared to existing cars on
the market and yeah what I would like to
see is an actual 1060 successor at the
250 dollar price point I mean let me be
completely clear here I'm not
particularly excited by AMD overclocking
the our X 480 again but the resulting
product the rx 590 delivers anything up
to 16 percent more performance from the
Nvidia's offering in that price range
but for three hundred and fifty dollars
yeah I think the RT X 2060 is well worth
considering anyway that's where I'm
going to finish up for now as always
please do like and subscribe to support
the work we do here at digital foundry
ring the bell for instant notifications
whenever a new D F video emerges from
our labs and yes a big shout-out to our
loyal digital foundry patreon supporters
you're helping out far more than you
probably realize anyway that's all from
me for now thanks for making it all the
way to the end of this one if indeed you
did and I'll see you soon